he passed it off and here's a chance the other way
and a score I'm telling you kucherov is going to
have a huge day after the way that skills thing
went last night it takes him 10 seconds into
his first shift and he's on the board steals a
Puck and off he goes and he beats Jake otinger
underneath the glove little deflection off the
glove but a a skills contest that did not go
very well for Nikita coocher off and a little
Bobble by Vincent troch leas pson to Vancouver
Canucks out their tremendous success there's
a shot to hit the post rre wasn't quite sure
that he had it but he did Alex to brinkin having
a terrific first season with his hometown team
in Detroit and a Nifty stop by talot that was
barzel through his legs he did it last night
this one goes off the pipe again Tal's had two
goalpost helpers here in the first minute or two
and now de Bret forsberg and it's right on of the
Stick of Alex to break it for a team Matthews goal
scores Matthews Connor to Brink it and gensel
he doesn't need many chances this is a great
pass from Philip forsberg right on the tape and
this goes underneath the bar just look at that
pass it's hard snapped on the tape and the brink
it doesn't miss a medical exam we hope he gets
healthy and rejoins the devils very [Applause]
soon Frank lonto scores in his first allstar
game at age 29 from the Anaheim Ducks the pride of
Western Massachusetts but tronto gives team Hughes
a two to1 lead Anaheim this is a long feed from
camp talber and I talked to Frank just as he was
getting into the bench here and when he came up
in Boston he was a a maybe sort of guy maybe he
could maybe he won't make it but he could really
shoot and he's made himself a legit NHL and going
to be a lot of interest around Frank to patrano
with the trade deadline here's a two on0 and a go
now looks to Brink it with two already for team
Matthews the beams loved it kucherov to break it
twice and the trotle the goal scores in this one
nice passing and a good stop by AER lots of fancy
stick handling by forsberg from the Nashville
Predators Kyle Conor denied Quinn Hughes played
it back Brady K Chuck down low all alone nice
stop by ainger here's coocher off again pson free
Puck 4 seconds to go in the period Patterson again
stopped by otinger and it's cleared from the goal
mouth Jak AER with the third player pick
by team Matthews with only a couple of M
Poli Leafs ahead of him elander and marer they go
two here's Miner and he
scores it's martyr the Toronto Maple [Applause]
Leafs when the goalies talk about this is not a
goalie friendly format as you see the be this is
why look how much room Marner has to come in think
about what he's going to do and make one more
move he makes the de to the middle and the shot
is perfect and they've got the lead 3-2 [Applause]
Quin Hughes nice pass ahead for Conor and it's a
break in for vrono and a Nifty glove save by
shurin Le to a quick counter the other way for
Matthews and he got denied by Patcher [Applause]
Demco knee Lander for fellow mapela Austin
Matthews and then kneel Lander lost the
puck coer up trying to go couple of leaps
racing to get back they won't stop him
and the goalie did they just took off and
he was brilliant 14 goals in the month of
January tied Sam Reinhardt of Florida for
the leak lead in go in January here's vrono
down low and they score Pon redirected it
[Music] in team Hughes get it's the puck
back vatrano to patteron and it's tied to
three team Matthews in blue they crowd the
net again forsberg barzel and tro check the
line they [Applause] score jammed in at
the front of the net by Philip forsberg
for the Nashville Predators and team Matthews
with another one-goal lead Predators history
is Philip forsberg yet had a beautiful assist
assist in the first period to set up to Brink
it here he gets to the front of the net and
stop once but the puck just kind of hanging
there and he's able just to slide it in that
man he's a such a big strong three on one across
the Blue Line Kyle Conor for kachuck and it's
[Applause] blocked here's kachuck again and he
scores Mar kachuck sorry Ray the captain of
the Ottawa Senators just tied in for team
Hughes Marner was getting some Love From the
Bench for cock's first chance right here with
the back of his leg wasn't really trying
to block it look at him yeah look at me
I blocked it but then Brady kachuck scores
and mder goes ah man what am I going to do
when Quinn Hughes picked his longtime friend
Brady kachuck he said why'd you pick up he
says look I want to go through this weekend
with those that I can that are close to be
kachuck so give them a one-goal lead with 225
to go man that's a great release vetrano came
off the bench he had changed for Brady kachuck
look at that pass from Quinn Hughes man he's
facing one way he knows where vetrano is spins
around and beats him and vatrano snaps it by
the Blocker of shurin so the golender gets
pulled at work for team McDavid in the first
game like their chances here florb
[Applause] [Music] SCS is second for team
Matthews this is a pretty slick play by
forsburg as he and de Brink it link up and
he goes over to his backhand side and goes
quickly back to the for and and look where
he puts it where Demco can't get his glove
to it it's over the wrist area of Demco as
he's trying to cover the bottom of the net
and forsberg beats him up top and it's tied
again he'll go back to his backand sometimes
and go back on his forehand and reach around
the right path trying to win it for
team Hughes and it rolled off his stick
as he made that move the shootout
goes to overtime Alex to break it
scores dragged this into his feet and then
beat thater demk and it's JT Miller of the
Vancouver Canucks in his first allstar game at
age 30 with a wide slow approach and gets poked
away team Matthews with celebrity
Captain Justin Bieber will advance